منطقه الشرق الاوسط مهمه جدا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا نجد هنا الشركاء الذين نثقوا
بهم نامل في تلقي دعم هذه المنطقه لتجاوز
الازمه الانسانيه والاقتصاديه في اوكرانيا
والتي نشات بسبب الغزو الروسي الشامل كانت
لدي سلسله مقابلات ممتازه خلال هذه الايام
امس الاول التقيت الرئيس الاماراتي الذي
استقبلنا بحراره وتم التوصل معه الى
اتفاقيه مهمه بالنسبه لي حيث تعهد بدعم
بناء 10 دور للايتام في اوكرانيا انه شكل
خاص للعنايه بالاطفال وبالاسر التي تتبنى
بين خمسه وعشره اطفال ايتام لتربيتهم انه
امل كبير بالنسبه لي وتامل مؤسسه اولينا
زيلينسكا الخيريه في استمرار هذا التعاون
لدينا امل كبير ونتوقع انضمام الدول
العربيه الاخرى الى التحالف من اجل دعم
اوكرانيا
نعتقد ان هذه الخطوه مهمه جدا من جانب
العالم العربي حيل اوكرانيا انا متاكده
ولدي ملء الثقه ان هذا الدعم سيصل
[موسيقى]
دول المنطقه يعني بغرار الدعم المالي هناك
ايضا دعم بموضوع تبادل الاسرى وايجاد
قنوات مفتوحه بين اوكرانيا وروسيا هل يعني
هذا الدور سيتطور بالمرحله المقبله يجب ان
يستمر لان الاسرى موجودون واذا لم تتم
اعادتهم الى منازلهم لن تنتهي هذه الحرب
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فان نهايه الحرب ليست
فقط وقفه اطلاق النار على جبهه القتال
وانما يجب ان يترافق ذلك مع اعاده جميع
اسرانا واطفالنا الذين تمت سرقتهم
ونقلهم الى الاتحاد الروسي لدينا الاف
الاطفال الذين تم نقلهم الى الاتحاد
الروسي في شكل غير شرعي واذا لم يتم اتخاذ
هذه الخطوات فلن نشعر بان الحرب انتهت
[موسيقى]